one interesting thing though by the way
did happen
at this cyber symposium over the weekend
and it happened when steve bannon and
marjorie taylor green were on stage
because why not
and it's when steve bannon
suggested that marjorie taylor greene
should be the next speaker of the house
of representatives so here he is laying
out his grand plan
for marjory taylor green's future take a
look
and once we win the house do we have a
better speaker of the house than mtg
[Applause]
are we going to need her as speaker the
house to take it to the democrats
[Applause]
all right
let's let's let's remember something
here folks
this is an individual marjorie taylor
green who before
being elected
to the house of representatives in 2020
had never held elected office in her
life okay
she is a first-time first-term
politician that hasn't even served a
full term yet
that doesn't even have any committee
assignments and hasn't for over a year
and steve bannon is out there saying she
should be the speaker of the house of
representatives
because nothing matters anymore at this
point
everything is a joke so sure why not
right
now
i'm sure once you get into the house
you're going to find that most
republicans in there are
going to say no to that and it's not
because they despise marjorie taylor
green but it's because
they've paid their dues
and she hasn't
she is still a freshman representative
that doesn't even serve on any
committees heck even lauren bobert's on
committees
but not green
you have literally no power
you can't even direct money back to your
district
because of your behavior that got you
stripped of those committee assignments
and steve bannon's out here
saying she should be the speaker of the
house
now i know right now that is a
far-fetched idea right folks
four years from now maybe not
i mean matt gates has hinted
at making jim jordan
the speaker of the house if republicans
take back the house of representatives
they don't want mccarthy they view him
as weak
and if these you know kind of oddballs
your your matt gates's and jordans and
greens and gomer's and those folks
if they all band together
and possibly even expand their numbers
in this year's midterms then yes we
could be looking at a situation where
the worst of the worst
becomes the speaker of the house of
representatives
they've made it clear i mean bannon made
it clear they want the worst people you
could ever imagine
to be up there
and and i don't think he's joking
even mike lindell is like a fighter true
a patriot all that oh yeah she's great
they love her
the rest of america not so much
so
let's assume for a second republicans
get this you know horrible monkeys paul
type wish
and uh they make her speaker of the
house what happens in two years after
that
i think we would see another blue wave
kind of like we did in 2018
because i think
putting lunacy
on display
putting arrogance instead of
intelligence
on display for the republican party is a
death sentence
and most normal
republicans understand that
you know kevin mccarthy knows that
dan crenshaw knows that i mean it's so
weird
that crenshaw is being attacked as a
rhino
you know he's a very extreme republican
but apparently still not extreme enough
to not get attacked as a rhino
we're living in topsy-turvy world here
people i don't understand what is going
on with this republican party all i know
is that if you want to get ahead
you've got to act like the most
ridiculous human being you ever have and
that's kind of why marjory taylor-green
of course showed up at
mike lindell's weekend event